说话人 1: 你好，我是Jason，今天给你们带来如何逆转女性的高位框架，从而让女生主动约你，主动成为一个舔狗
说话人 1: OK，我先说一下这个视频的背景，他是在我的代聊群里面的一个大群里面，我的学员，让我帮他全程代聊，把这个妹子的框架完全逆转，让妹子成为舔狗
说话人 1: 这是一个在的APP，就是一个牵手的APP
说话人 1: 上面的一个女生，整体给人感觉是非常的长情，也没谈过多少恋爱，所以说是一个传统的一个女生
说话人 1: 看我们来怎么操作，把她变成一个舔狗
说话人 1: OK，我们来看一下，首先学员开始打招呼，早上好
说话人 1: 这个女生问他苏州哪里，这个学员说姑苏区这边
说话人 1: OK，这是学员开局的一个信息的一个处理
说话人 1: OK，这里我是没有参与的，他是后面在群里问我，他说这个怎么回
说话人 1: OK，这个时候我们就要布局，因为女生
说话人 1: 说了，他说你在上大学吗
说话人 1: 这个时候可能按兄弟们正常的一个思维逻辑
说话人 1: 会正常回答她这个问题，我没有上学，我在上学，对吧
说话人 1: 也有些可能兄弟觉得他说他在上学会很幼稚，女生不会接受他，他就会骗女生说他没有上学
说话人 1: OK，这个时候到时候约会，她会拆穿你，这样就不好
说话人 1: 所以说我给了一个比较中立的一个答案，同时他也没有那么的幼稚，我回了一个是弟弟，但是不太弟
说话人 1: 什么意思
说话人 1: 我长得像个弟弟，可能我的外形比较弟，但是我的内在不是弟弟
说话人 1: 没有那么情绪化，没有那么扯淡，是这样的一个意思，想传达给这个女生
说话人 1: 首先这个话我们是要这样去处理，但是这个女生她不一定段位有那么高，她不一定能理解这句话，但是我们还是要打这样的一个牌，知道吧
说话人 1: 这样才不会犯错
说话人 1: 然后这个女生她还在追问，她说在不在读书啊
说话人 1: 这个时候我给了一个非常强框架的一个答案，很多兄弟害怕这样的一个回复，就是所以你放弃了吗
说话人 1: 不敢发这样的东西，就万一怕女生真的说，啊我放弃了，然后把他删掉
说话人 1: 很多兄弟是不敢这样回答的，但是这种东西越在前期做，你越能知道女生的窗口，越能知道你现在的一个胜率
说话人 1: 所以说我们要立刻做出这样的一个东西，而且同时我有足够的把握，这把不会爆，所以说我才会发这么强的一个东西
说话人 1: 这个是要根据社交直觉来的，然后我说在啊，所以你放弃了吗
说话人 1: 说我在读书，你不要跟你接触了吗
说话人 1: 说我要反问她，吊出她的一个需求感，然后这个女生上钩了，她说哈哈哈，为什么要放弃
说话人 1: OK，这个时候就
说话人 1: 差不多成功了，这个时候我回了一句，我说我不喜欢我的年龄，这是一个什么样的技巧
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这是一个自我失格，自我失格它是一个比较强大的技巧，但是前提是你要有足够的吸引力，如果说你没有足够的吸引力，你去使用自我失格，那么女生就真的会离开你
说话人 1: 但是如果说你的吸引力足够，你使用出自我失格，这会让女生更加的想要舔你
说话人 1: 所以说我给出了这样的一个技巧，来调出女人更多的一个购买欲
说话人 1: 女生她跟上来了，她说为啥
说话人 1: OK，这一句为啥其实就是一个购买欲的增加
说话人 1: 如果说这个女生不上钩，或者说这个女生对你购买欲不强，她会说，哦，无所谓，为什么
说话人 1: 她不想了解你的你的过去，她不想了解你的思想
说话人 1: 你为什么不喜欢年龄小的
说话人 1: 你为什么不喜欢你的年龄比较小
说话人 1: 知道吗
说话人 1: 所以说这是上钩了
说话人 1: 女生她接着来迎合你，知道吧
说话人 1: 她说我年龄女的，就是她也是比较小的，主动给出她自己的一个岁数，让你来做调整
说话人 1: 这是一个比较好的信号，它相当于是一个复合了
说话人 1: 这个时候我回了一句，一，我不想靠脸吃饭
说话人 1: 真的，我为什么要回这样的一个东西
说话人 1: 这个学员他的 SMV 是比较高的，他的价值是比较高的，他在签售里面的照片也是比较 OK 的
说话人 1: 所以说我会拿这一个点去给女生进行测试，就是OK，我不想靠脸吃饭，我想靠我自己的内在，靠我的成熟度来获得感情，来获得我想要的一个爱情
说话人 1: 这一点可以给到女人很强的一个价值感，就是没有那么肤浅，没有那么装逼，这是在后面能让她框架逆转，能让她做深度吸引的一个前提条件，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，然后这个女生她不懂，可能她的经历比较少，可能她不太确定，有可能她知道这个意思，但是她不太确定，她还是要问你，这个时候兄弟们可能就有些慌，但其实这是一个正常现象，如果说她没听懂，那么就补充就行了，如果说她假装的听不懂，那么也可以
说话人 1: 知道吗
说话人 1: 他是游刃有余，进退自如的
说话人 1: 这个时候我说了，都只是舔狗，那些女人我不喜欢
说话人 1: 这是一个什么样的意思
说话人 1: 我在做了一个隐含的社交认证，我身边的女人非常的多，对吧
说话人 1: 但是这些女人她其实都是看脸的，她都是很肤浅的，她没有深入的了解我的内在，知道吗
说话人 1: 我是在符合这个女人，在引导这个女人来跟我进行一个深度交流，而不是表面上那些肉体关系
说话人 1: 这是一个很高级的技巧，深度引导
说话人 1: OK，然后这个女生她迎合了我的这个风格，她说，哦，明白了，那你不颜控吗
说话人 1: 你上大几
说话人 1: 大三吗
说话人 1: 这个时候女生发出了非常多的话题点，你们很多时候觉得女生不知道怎么接女生的话，你们不知道怎么去引导话题，你要从女生的话里面去接着引导这个话题，但是要去选好的一个点，要选跟你
说话人 1: 有关的一个点，不要去乱选，去被女生带偏了，变成好朋友
说话人 1: 这个时候我直接给出我的标准，我说盐合格就好，我更在乎长期的体验，毕竟盐保质期比较短
说话人 1: OK，这是什么
说话人 1: 这是我在种植一个长期的关系
说话人 1: 在这里我要给兄弟们澄清一下，长期关系不是你想的那种，一对一，OK，我要遵守这个女人，我要一直迎合这个女人，她不是长期关系
说话人 1: 那叫供养关系
说话人 1: 我说的长期关系就是我跟这个女生可以长时间的跑友，长时间的在一起，同时我也可以接触其他女生，这叫我的长期关系
说话人 1: 你们不要理解错误了，不要觉得他们啊，这个是只会玩长期关系
说话人 1: 我只能说你们对情感的认知太差了
说话人 1: 然后这个女生疯狂的在迎合我，她说哎呦，我也是，那你能追我吗
说话人 1: 我很好追的
说话人 1: 兄弟们，你们看这个女生她的购买欲已经这么强了，她还在引导你去舔她，知道吗
说话人 1: 因为她可能在从前的恋爱关系中，都是男生舔她
说话人 1: 这个时候我们还是要坚持自己的东西，不要她说她很好追，你真的去追
说话人 1: 那你就完了，对不对
说话人 1: 女生，你只要达到她的临界点，她会反过来倒追你，这就是我的聊天逻辑
说话人 1: 然后他说一追就追到了，这个时候我发出了一个非常屌的一个话术，我说我都还不了解你，什么意思
说话人 1: 就是现在还太早了，我还要看看你能拿出更多的诚意，你要拿出更多的筹码来跟我谈这一次合作，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，像不像女生跟你们说
说话人 1: 兄弟们，像不像女生跟你们说，我很慢热
说话人 1: 我们现在认识的太早了，我们才认识这么久，我们才认识一会就要出来约咖啡吗
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 像女生在飞车里一样，兄弟们，你们要学习好这样的一个推开，你只有推开才能让女生更多的一个付出
说话人 1: 然后兄弟们看，这个女生说哈哈，那好吧，那要怎么了解呢
说话人 1: 兄弟们，女生完全上钩了，知道吗
说话人 1: 女生在等你给她条件，女生在等你给她一些规则
说话人 1: 到这个时候我就知道一切定局就已经 ok 了，后面的只是按顺序操作而已，到这个时候已经成定局了，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这个时候我直接给出我要的氛围，我要的需求，当面去操作，所以说我只回了一个当面
说话人 1: 很多兄弟们想把这个话变得更多，想把这个话变得更有趣，变得更幽默，但其实没有任何卵用
说话人 1: 我告诉你们，字越少，越像我这样简洁，才有好的一个作用，才有一个价值感
说话人 1: 女生说，她说真的吗
说话人 1: 哈哈，那你一般什么时候有空呢
说话人 1: 兄弟们，像不像你在问女生，你什么时候有空
说话人 1: 我什么时候可以约你
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 你在争取这个女生的你的同意，像不像
说话人 1: 框架已经完全的逆转了，这个时候我们不要马上给出那个时间，我们还要继续的玩弄她，继续的营造价值感
说话人 1: 所以这个时候我又做了一个推开，我说你得先保证不会卖了我的肾，对吧
说话人 1: 又引导她出现一个副歌，她说啊，我不是那种坏女人，我不是那种坏人，我不会他们的伤害你，对不对
说话人 1: 兄弟们
说话人 1: 角色完全逆转，现在这个女生像不像你们在舔一个正妹，对吧
说话人 1: 现在我聊的这个角色是不是一个正妹
说话人 1: 好好体验那种感觉，兄弟们
说话人 1: 这个时候我们又拉一把，目前看来很随和，兄弟们可能学了我的框架，学了我的体系，可能就会一直推推推，但是我告诉你们，拉回来的操作也很重要，知道吗
说话人 1: 你只有拉回来，这个女人才知道你是可以触碰的，你不是那种高高在上的
说话人 1: 他就会放弃，知道吧
说话人 1: 这个女生她得到了奖励，她说那必须的，她也挺开心，她得到了奖励
说话人 1: 她立刻又来一个什么兴趣指标，她问你是什么星座
说话人 1: 一般女生问你星座，她不一定是兴趣指标，我给兄弟们，我先给兄弟们说，这个要结合前后文，结合当前的女性状态，你才能知道她是不是一个兴趣指标
说话人 1: 但是我可以告诉兄弟们，在这里她问你是什么星座，这就是一个兴趣指标，你已经彻底的知道这个女生
说话人 1: 被你迷住了
说话人 1: 学员他自己回了一个，我的星座不渣，你猜，这应该是以前我用过的一个话术
说话人 1: 当时是我没有回复他，他自己回复了一个
说话人 1: 女生说，她说我不知道啊，不知道渣的是什么星座
说话人 1: OK，可能这个女生她的情感经历太少，也可能她想装一下，无所谓，我们接着引导
说话人 1: 不要慌，兄弟们，不要，这个女生为什么她不知道我应该怎么回
说话人 1: 知道吧
说话人 1: 你需要，OK，多一点引导性，无视掉妹子的一些反应，不要一个妹子，反应好，你就很开心，哈哈大笑，妹子反应不好，你就，哎
说话人 1: OK，然后学员回了一个，就射手那些吧，你是什么
说话人 1: OK，我记得当时这前面几个回复都是我在直播的时候口头给他说的，所以说没在群里发
说话人 1: 因为当时直播帮很多兄弟聊天，都是口头让他们回复的
说话人 1: 女生说她是双子，问我是什么
说话人 1: 这个时候我在群里让这个兄弟回复，我说白羊，其实我不信星座
说话人 1: 兄弟们要有一个引导话题的，要有一个引导话题的能力，你回答了一个问题之后，你要抛一个锚点，让女生去抓住这个锚点去回复，这会让你
说话人 1: 源源不断的一个话题
说话人 1: 不要女生问你多大了，你回个23，那就没了，对不对
说话人 1: 在什么情况你可以直接单独回这样的一个东西
说话人 1: 就是你的吸引足够的情况下，你可以单独回这样的一个东西，或者说你想切断这个对话的时候，你可以单独回这样的一个信息
说话人 1: 但是更多的时候你们需要去连接上一个话题，然后去接下去
说话人 1: 然后这个女生说，她说，哦，那确实不渣，没谈过
说话人 1: 然后这个时候我很疑惑，我不知道她说的是我没谈过
说话人 1: 还是她没谈过，所以这个时候我让学员回了一句，你还是我
说话人 1: 很多时候兄弟们要去，很多时候兄弟们无法理解这个女生的话，就不要乱去理解，你就直接把她摆到明面上去问出来就行了
说话人 1: 然后这个女生说她说不，这个时候我的脑子里有一个想法，她说她没谈过，我会想这个女生到底是一个什么样的情况
说话人 1: 然后这个时候我让学员回了一句，说我很好奇，这已经是在做一些深度的一点沟通了，他能挖出这个女生的一个联系感
说话人 1: 这是一个比较好的一个东西
说话人 1: 女生说，她说好奇什么
说话人 1: 我说你为什么没谈
说话人 1: 女生说，她说没有喜欢的人，所以没谈
说话人 1: 你呢
说话人 1: 这时候其实有两个话题可以接，第一个话题是没有喜欢的人，所以没谈，这是第一个话题，是关于她的，她其实是想引导我们去问她那个东西
说话人 1: 她还有第二个话题，你呢
说话人 1: 她想知道这个东西
说话人 1: OK，这个时候我会往我这方面引导，因为我其实不太想了解她，知道吧
说话人 1: 而且你去了解她的话，会让她拥有价值感
说话人 1: 这其实是不太好的，我会问，你能感觉出来几个
说话人 1: 我会想让她感觉我谈过几个的样子
说话人 1: 这个女生说什么意思
说话人 1: 隔了一会又说你回信息好慢
说话人 1: OK，到了这个时候就应该什么
说话人 1: 就应该转到微信，转到其他地方去聊，因为在这个 APP 上它其实不太好
说话人 1: 这个时候就直接转微信，这个时候并不唐突，也不会有需求感，它是很自然的一个转到微信的一个操作，你们可以复制一下这样的一个操作
说话人 1: 通过微信之后，这个女生还在追问，你说的我能感觉出来几个是什么意思
说话人 1: 我让学员回了谈过的数量
说话人 1: 你看，女生到这里还会在意你的情感经历，知道吗
说话人 1: 这是一个很强烈的兴趣指标
说话人 1: 简单来说，达到这样的操作，你跟她出去约会见面的时候，你只要不犯错，你只要不瞎扯淡，对吧
说话人 1: 你都能把她收尾
说话人 1: 这是一个非常现实的问题，非常有逻辑性的一个问题，它不是一种玄学
说话人 1: 这个女生说，她说猜不出来，我只谈过两个
说话人 1: 她说我也会游泳，哈哈
说话人 1: 因为这个学员他的朋友圈发了一个游泳的一个视频
说话人 1: 你看这个女生，她把朋友圈刷了，她来问出这个问题，可见她的兴趣指标有多么强烈
说话人 1: 简单来说就是这个女生现在已经变成一只大舔狗了
说话人 1: 这个时候兄弟们不要被她的话题所引导歪了，我们还是要抓住最主要的东西去聊
说话人 1: 女生不喜欢跟你聊什么游泳，跟你聊什么乒乓球，跟你聊什么美妆
说话人 1: 知道吗
说话人 1: 跟你聊什么宠物，女生不喜欢跟你聊这些，你抓住重点，搞定重点问题，知道吗
说话人 1: 兄弟们，这个非常的重要
说话人 1: 所以说我回了，你应该不喜欢谈的少的，这个女生他们的非常的舔啊，她说喜欢一个人跟谈的多少有什么关系
说话人 1: 简单来说，她不管你谈的多谈的少，她都喜欢，对吧
说话人 1: 这就是舔狗，这太扯淡了
说话人 1: 所以说这个女生太容易了，其实就完全没有挑战性，而且完全不会有那种珍惜的感觉，因为他他们的喜欢一个人太容易了，他就没有标准，知道吗
说话人 1: 舔狗是没有标准的
说话人 1: 这个女生她说你回消息慢，我恨你
说话人 1: OK，她有点不满意回消息的速度
说话人 1: OK，这个时候需要拉回一下，不要他们一直强框架强框架，对吧
说话人 1: 这个时候我说你习惯一下我事情多，来合理化我回消息慢的一个操作
说话人 1: 这个东西要在前期都要做好，如果说你一直去逃避这样的问题，那么他到了后期就一定会让你变得很狼狈，让你被你们的道德所绑架，知道吗
说话人 1: 所以说一定要在前期就处理好这样的一个东西
说话人 1: 女生说，她说，哦，对了，你在上大几啊
说话人 1: 其实她问这个问题，其实她并不想知道你上大几，她只是找不到话说了，她想去把话题转移，可能张力比较强，可能她想跟你聊的更多，这个时候我们就回答，看她到底想搞什么名堂
说话人 1: 这个时候女生她说出了她的一个终极的目的，原来她想知道你上大几，忙不忙
说话人 1: 是哪个时候有时间
说话人 1: 她想摸清楚你的底细
说话人 1: 她就直接问了，她说你一般什么时候有空呢
说话人 1: 对吧
说话人 1: 兄弟们，到了这个时候可能你们才会看出来，原来女生是想约他，对吧
说话人 1: 原来女生是想约他出来
说话人 1: 但其实不是，在最开始我都已经知道了，只是说到这个时候，她具象化出来，你能更好的能理解这样的一个东西
说话人 1: 这个时候我让学员自己去调度
说话人 1: 这就差不多是个水到渠成的一个事情，非常简单的一个邀约，但是她是女生主动邀约，而且是框架逆转，知道吧
说话人 1: 全程都是一个非常强的一个价值感
说话人 1: 女生说，她说，哦，那我们可以约会吗
说话人 1: 哈哈，太扯淡了，知道吧
说话人 1: 这完全就像一个舔狗的口气
说话人 1: 这个时候学员不知道约什么地方，我让学员回约小酒馆怎么样
说话人 1: OK，约小酒馆的话，它会比较好调情，比较好升级，快速的进入到一个私密空间进行收尾
说话人 1: 因为酒精它能让人的星语，让人的一些迷走神经松弛掉，就会让他更容易去吐露自己，更容易发出他自己的一个信号
说话人 1: OK，兄弟们想快速收尾的话，可以去小酒馆，但是我本人我是不愿意约小酒馆的，因为我本人不喝酒，我也不想很快速的一个收尾，因为已经过了那种很刺激的一个阶段，我现在是一个比较平和，比较螺旋向上的一个阶段，所以我个人来讲是不推荐小酒馆，但是你们想快速收尾，你们
说话人 1: 年轻，你想要快速的释放，那么可以去约小酒馆，而且我推荐你们去小酒馆
说话人 1: OK，这就是一个完整的一个邀约，逆转框架的一个聊天流程，兄弟们可以学习到非常多的一种价值感，一种框架感，它并不是一种他们的很装逼，去骂女人，去搞女人
说话人 1: 很多兄弟们可能会误解，也有一些内鬼在我的群里面去截一些不好的图，去找一些很的图，去
说话人 1: 其他地方乱传，说杰克逊这个人就是喜欢骂女人，喜欢搞女人，所谓的硬框架，但其实不是
说话人 1: 所谓的高位框架，它是一种柔和的东西，它是一种包容，它不是一种他们的非要攻击针对，知道吗
说话人 1: 它是一种包容
说话人 1: 我们的高位，我们的高框架，我们的硬框架是要根据现实来打回去，而现实它不是攻击人
说话人 1: 如果说你觉得现实在攻击你，那么肯定就是你这个人不符合现实
说话人 1: 这个人就是错误的，所以说我们要用现实去证实眼前的一个事情
说话人 1: OK，大家以后要好好学习一个高位框架，逆转框架的一个操作
说话人 1: 这里是真实社交，我是Jaser，下期再见，兄弟们